[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 9 mai bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78 tour
d'horizon de l'actualité locale et
régionale
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition vacances de printemps ont du
mois de mai une période sous tension
pour le don du sang un appel à la
mobilisation a été lancée en
ile-de-france pour éviter la pénurie de
produits sanguins donner un geste qui
sauve des vies
reportage au centre du collecte du
chesnay le réseau stibus va évoluer à la
rentrée prochaine sur le territoire à
partir de septembre 2000 sans cours
supplémentaires seront proposés aux
usagers est dé renforcement de l'offre
et des tracés et modifié à saint quentin
en yvelines dans ce journal le point
complet sur les nouveautés
et puis retour sur la 10e édition
d'esprit jardin elle se déroulait le
week-end dernier dans le quartier saint
louis de versailles le rendez vous a
réuni sous le soleil 80 des exposants et
de nombreux visiteurs amateurs comme
professionnels
alors que certains pensent déjà en
vacances ou sont en congé en ce moment
avec cette semaine des ponts pour
d'autres c'est l'heure de la rentrée
l école le web force 3 a ouvert
aujourd'hui à trappes
elle est installée au sein de la
pépinière d'entreprises chrysalis situé
dans le quartier des merisiers ils sont
douze à suivre une formation de trois
mois et demi pour devenir et développeur
intégrateur web écouter est la
directrice au micro de marylène
iapichino et de manon varaldo les douze
personnes qui intègre la formation sont
demandeurs d'emploi al c'est vraiment
une formation professionnalisante
l'objectif c'est de ce soit un levier un
levier d'insertion professionnelle donc
c'est également pour ça que les élus ont
souhaité que nous nous installions sur
le territoire c'est vraiment pour
permettre aux entreprises du territoire
qui recrutent d'avoir ddd personnes des
personnes qualifiées pour pour
travailler vers ces métiers
le don du sang est un geste qui peut
sauver des vies mais qui se fait rare en
ce mois de mai où les ponts sont
nombreux le ffs l'établissement français
du sang ile de france a lancé un appel à
la mobilisation
objectif éviter une pénurie à d'ici les
prochaines semaines
exemple dans les îles
lino enchaînait avec ce sujet daury les
ronces et de manon varaldo si ce mois de
mai est synonyme de bonheur pour la
plupart des salariés pour
l'établissement français du sang il est
plutôt source de stress comme ici aux
chaînés les produits sanguins collectés
ont une durée de vie limitée
le plasma peut se conserver un an mais
seulement 42 jours pour les globules
rouges et 5 jours pour les plaquettes
malgré la mobilisation des franciliens
depuis le début du mois à la situation
reste tendue
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que la
maladie elle elle ne fais pas le con
elle ne prend pas de vacances qu'avec un
don de sang nous pouvons soigner trois
patients nous produisons un concentré de
globules rouges
nous produisons un plasma thérapeutique
et nous produisons également des
plaquettes grâce aux dons de sang et de
fait ces dons de sang sont essentiels
tout du jour de l'année en france dix
mille dons par jour sont nécessaires
pour répondre aux besoins des malades
pour effectuer ce geste qui peut sauver
des vies il n'est pas nécessaire de
prendre rendez vous il suffit d'être en
bonne santé
des trajets entre 18 et 70 ans et peser
plus de 50 kg compter deux heures
entretien prélèvements et collation
comprise
moi c'est assez naturel en fait de
donner son sens quand on est en bonne
santé pour pouvoir aider les autres
donc en fait j'ai attendu avec
impatience d'avoir 18 ans et de pouvoir
donner mon sang et maintenant j'en ai 19
et c'est la deuxième fois que je me sens
et je compte continuer encore longtemps
les l'excusent de la peur des aiguilles
bon je pense qu'après une fois qu'on l'a
fait on s'aperçoit que c'est pas
compliqué et puis c'est pour moi c'est
et ça fait partie du show ce qu'on
devrait faire sans se poser de questions
dans les yvelines il existe deux sites
fixes de prélèvement à poissy et
enchaîné des collectes mobiles sont
également organisées régulièrement aux
quatre coins du département
à chaque rentrée à son lot de nouveautés
à partir de septembre prochain le réseau
de bus s'étoffe à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines scribus
proposera notamment des cours
supplémentaires certaines mines seront
renforcées
l'offre intensifier les week-ends et le
soir le point sur ce qui évolue avec
marion de tak et patrick jacques de
dixmude pour la rentrée 2010 8,7 un tout
nouveau réseau de bus qu'accueillera le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
restructurer un réseau parfois caduque
telle était la volonté de
l'agglomération nous allons commencer
dès le mois de février je crois 2016 à
travailler avec l'ensemble des douze
maires pour voir comment on pouvait
remettre à plat le réseau de bus voir ce
qui était pertinent voire les lignes qui
étaient grenelle ii qu emprunté celle
qu'il est témoin et si les deux tours m
sur la table via des questionnaires les
attend de trois mille usagers ont permis
l'amélioration du réseau certains tracés
ont été créés comme la ligne 8 qui
reliera la gare de villepreux les clés à
celle de plaisir gueugnon le réseau sera
également renforcée en soirée et le
week-end
puis-je 10% de course lors de ces
périodes nous n'avions pas beaucoup de
bus le week-end padoue le soir donc
maintenant nous allons avoir des bus 7
jours sur 7 jusqu'à minuit sur certaines
mines ce qui n'existait pas il comprit
débute ce dimanche
les itinéraires des bus se rééquilibre
pour permettre aux villes telles que
magny les hameaux de bénéficier plus
facilement du réseau de saint quentin
autre ambition augmenter les fréquences
et réduire le temps d'attenté aux heures
de pointe
elle arrive à garder l'express alors les
lignes express ça ce sont des lignes qui
seront en voie en heure de pointe tous
les cas rebord et sinon à la demi heure
ça n'existait pas sur nos sur nos lignes
actuelles ou parfois mais il fallait
même attendre parfois plus d'une heure
pour voir plus pour pour avoir un bus
qui fait que finalement au bout d'un
certain temps d'attendre les gens
prennent leur voiture en tout 2000 sans
cours supplémentaires par an seront
réalisés à partir du 3 septembre
prochain afin de faciliter encore plus
le déplacement de la population
c'est le rendez vous de tous les
passionnés du 7e art le festival de
cannes s'est ouvert hier mardi une 71e
édition qui se clôturera le 19 mai où
est présente cette année encore l'île de
france est la région a soutenu cinq
films sélectionnés au festival
le long métrage les âmes mortes du
réalisateur chinois wang bing dans la
sélection officielle catégorie séance
spéciale
et puis dans la quinzaine des
réalisateurs un festival parallèle
joueurs de mari mange plus grosse
subvention régionale à 298 1000 euros
est la route des samouni de l'italien
stefano savona les silences par béatrice
seigner enfin autre grand financement
par l'île de france
amine de philippe faucon est l'histoire
d'un sénégalais venus travailler en
france et qui a laissé au pays épouses
et enfants
un jour il rencontre une femme avec qui
une relation se noue alors ça y est vous
allez terminer
vous en voulez encore donné je me
débarrasse
en 2018 la région a consacré un budget
de 25 millions d'euros au cinéma et à
l'audiovisuel elle sachez que tv 78
prendra ses quartiers à cannes la
semaine prochaine chaque jour dans nos
éditions focus sur les yvelinois présent
sur la croisette
alors que le festival s'est ouvert hier
eux ont justement décidé de réinventer
le 7e art la semaine dernière la troupe
de déclic théâtre présentait son dernier
spectacle sur le cinéma un spectacle sur
le cinéma au grenier à sel à trappes
or ils iront et nicolas landry ont suivi
ce spectacle de la formule 1 sur une
musique du film flashdance un mélange
des genres que vous propose la troupe de
déclic théâtre avec son spectacle plan c
donner l'illusion aux spectateurs qu'ils
sont au cinéma à travers des
improvisations de 20 minutes
le concept le public choisit une image
une musique ainsi qu'un titre
les comédiens parts de ces trois
éléments pourront faire une histoire
comédie drame western
les possibilités sont multiples ce qui a
demandé un gros travail de préparation
pour la troupe
on s'est réuni on a regardé plein de
leicester on a regardé plein de films
policiers ont en fait on a voilà on a
essayé de se créer vraiment une culture
commune pour les comédiens de plans
c'est pour que quand on se dise ok on va
jouer à un thriller et ben on a tous la
même référence de thriller et on sait où
on parlait première chose qu'on se dit
c'est récupérer les codes assez
rapidement pour que ça parle à
l'imaginaire commun des spectateurs pour
que en fait ils puissent se dire c'est
vrai que c'est les trams des westerns
habituel et on reconnaît le genre de
film un spectacle d'une heure quinze qui
aura nécessité un nom et demi de
réflexion
on est dans un dans un format qui permet
au public de voir de voir plusieurs
facettes de ce qu'on peut travailler on
n'est pas frustré si on vient voir
voilà une impro qu'elle dure 1h30 ou une
heure et que finalement ce soit juste
une impro complètement dramatique et
puis qu'on n'ait pas trouvé ce qu'on est
venu chercher
donc on s'est dit voilà au moins avec
3,1 brouille en a il ya en a pour tout
le monde
le spectacle se joue dans les cinémas de
proximité prochain rendez vous le 10
juin à saint cyr l'école et plus d'infos
et culturels à suivre après ce journal
dans le 7-8 culture de mélanie poker un
mot de sport avec la ryder cup 2018 on
commence à y voir plus clair sur
l'encadrement de l'équipe européenne à
moins de six mois de l'événement à saint
quentin en yvelines a finalement pas de
vice capitaine français comme attendu
sur les greens du golf national en
septembre et mes deux tricolores nommés
au sein des assistants leur nom raphaël
jacquelin et grégory havret qui ont
disputé de nombreux tournois dont l'open
de france de golf
ils n'ont aucune expérience de la ryder
cup les deux français auront notamment
pour mission de faire le lien entre les
membres du staff le public et la presse
il pourrait également accompagné les
joueurs sur le parcours on poursuit avec
eux du basket les moins de 13 ans de
maurepas champion des yvelines ils ont
engrangé ce week-end leur neuvième
victoire sur neuf matches disputés cette
saison
score final 47 31 contre le chesnay
versailles
retour sur la rencontre et sur la fête
avec mitel et demi d'euros et nicolas
landry
dernières consignes de l'entraîneur
alexis dû monter avant le match le plus
important de l'année pour les moins de
13 ans de l'équipe de maurepas en cas de
victoire ce samedi contre le chesnay
versailles ces joueurs pourraient
soulever le titre de champion la
concentration est maximale pendant le
match
[Musique]
comme sur les dernières rencontres les
moins patients dominé remporte cette
première période 27 à treize et je vends
se dirige vers un sans faute en
championnat avec 9 victoires en 9
matches disputés les résultats acquis
grâce au travail de l'entraîneur sont
les parents des joueurs ont senti mais
elle joue très juste et droit dans ses
baskets donc c'est parfait c'est ce team
collective qui ressort puis ceux de
cette équipe et tout le monde peut
prendre la place de tout le monde est un
bon groupe qui s'est formé bon repas
s'impose finalement 47 à 31 contre son
adversaire du jour en maîtrisant la
seconde période à l'expérience
c'est officiel le mur païen son champion
on s'en fout on est fiers monétiser nos
entraînements c'est qu'elle y travaille
on a beaucoup couru cette année c'est
deux ans de travail
l'année dernière on avait fini troisième
la star y ont fini champions donc il ya
comme une belle marge de progression
c'est super d'autres émotions sont
encore à prévoir dans les prochaines
semaines pour le bc maurepas avec cette
victoire la section jouera la finale
régionale pour le titre if de france les
joueurs eux ne sont pas prêts à
redescendre de leur nuage
on termine ce journal sur la dixième
édition d'esprit jardin qui se tenait ce
week-end à versailles shopping horticole
création végétale conseil animations
ludiques pour les enfants plus de 80
exposants étaient présents camille
lambert et patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
des chèvres et autres animaux de la
ferme au coeur du quartier saint louis
le spectacle aura de quoi surprendre
mais les visiteurs sont bien habitués
cela fait dix ans qu'esprit jardin
réunit les passionnés de jardinage dans
la cité royale
on était déjà venu l'année dernière
c'est
on prend du bon temps il fait très beau
il ya du soleil et puis ça permet de
faire découvrir aux enfants les plantes
et puis et puis on profite des animaux
de la ferme qui sont juste à côté
depuis trois ans qu'est ce qui vous
plaît dans les airs
l'ambiance les fleurs les stands et puis
le renouvellement tous les ans sur les
décorations comme sophie plus de 25000
visiteurs sont venus craqué sur les
végétaux et découvrir les nouveautés de
cette 10e édition
pour la première fois les curieux ont pu
se promener dans le jardin de la
cathédrale saint-louis jusque là fermé
au public
on avait envie de faire découvrir aux
gens ce petit jardin de la cathédrale au
petit jardin du presbytère qui a une qui
est tout à fait charmant et surtout qui
fait un peu comme on dirait jardin
secret on est dans un patrimoine
historique de la ville de versailles et
dans le saint louis qui est vraiment le
quartier le plus ancien de versailles du
parvis de la cathédrale jusqu'au potager
du roi un événement qui rend aussi
hommage au patrimoine végétal de la
ville un héritage dont andré le nôtre et
jean baptiste de la quintinie ont
construit la renommée c'est la fin de ce
journal belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]